yeah hello welcome to this video playing
maradona with why just going to be a
king's indian Petrosian slightly and
experimenting with this so please and
they had this against a minute earlier
game 97 I think you can play many moves
this is hailed on we had exactly the
same blind and only a game at his
position was completely unplayable after
the opening doing that a second time
that is pretty that's I don't know i
mean the disposition is already terrible
so okay I'm here probably f4 let's go
ahead for does at least look somewhat
somewhat turn yeah yeah somewhat unclear
[Music]
so what's going on
very very real position ok so I think
taking this looks good looks like a
decent start but from the end Knight f3
as an idea on and my king is unlike on
everyone is also somewhat somewhat open
of course to do this
yeah i think i'm going to start with
this move and and and go from here a
couple of interesting things that I can
do if I've as possible you should be for
it's also possible or look h6 just
looking at this pawn also getting the
Queen getting this doubled would be
would be interesting I think I put this
out in first out of the f phone ok it
looks very dangerous
so look aged six would be the first
thought let's do it my bishop is coming
to deform yeah like survives this that
set would be amazing okay so Bishop f4 I
sorry bishop d for heinous the capture
on f4 with a check
and you need some those miracles you
need that they that they work the set
who would like little pig little bit
incredible
[Music]
the a bishop before you can really take
on x 4 as weird as it is that's the case
maybe I just have to prepare this one
move like with this for example I don't
know I have to play move at some point
after this Bishop before I don't know if
you can defend it SI phan I'm taking we
should be for threatening group h eight
mate so this is a pretty substantial
threat
he also cannot really move this Bishop
sg6 is hanging I don't see a defense but
I'm really not good at finding resources
from opponent never been yeah here at
win takes h5 should win at least that's
an ending a look up but maybe I can do
something else time you're late ok I'll
do it I saw this winning idea bit
earlier Luke h8 made now and the queen
of the tech black resign so it's um it's
a ruka essentially I think this is just
a very bad way of playing Bishop g5
whatever was more interesting than what
you did in the in the earlier game when
you played f5 which was really awful ok
maybe here h6 is given by the engine it
is a tricky position check here White
King is also in some yeah in an unusual
situation at five I took this 93 back
and indie to this is what a clear
situation his Bishop g5 was certainly
better than the earlier tribe and now he
relatively quickly decided on this and
this out there the computer gives why
the winning position with this route h6
and we should be flan instead of the
Queen move but the Queen move also seems
to win
now tg1 tweenage form was that bad what
ended not necessarily also with and this
does that when it does win okay yeah it
I wasn't entirely sure if there's maybe
some weird defense that I was missing
but there is nothing this is the
specialty form and now queen age five is
the cleanest women you know so look h8
made or yeah it wins the Queen basically
have to give this up now and why then is
a look up ok guys thanks for watching